en el último debate antes de las
elecciones el izquierdista gabriel boric
y el ultraderechista josé antonio kast
buscar en el centro las protestas de
2019 y el actual proceso constituyente
marcaron el inicio
pregunta es quien generó esa violencia
extrema no fue la ciudadanía que tenía
legítimo derecho a manifestarse
muy radicales y nosotros nos oponíamos a
un acuerdo forzado por la violencia
extrema y yo tengo muy claro de que
ninguna posición se puede atrincherar en
un lugar en donde diga todo nada
los candidatos debatieron temas de
interés para los chilenos tanto sociales
como económicos boris líder de la
coalición apruebo dignidad se distanció
de las propuestas más marchistas del
programa cast candidato del partido
republicano se alejó de opiniones
anteriores contrarias a los derechos el
eje ético más en el debate cruzado se
produjo el mayor enfrentamiento de la
noche espero espero que los chilenos
tengan claro que una persona que sólo
pide perdón cuando se le pilla en una
acción incorrecta puede tener otras
otros temas pendientes también yo creo
que la gente sabe
en su casa las caricaturas que ha
instalado la campaña del terror que ha
instalado josé antonio kast quizás la
más sucia desde la época de la dictadura
la que usted apoyó y que éste finalmente
versión pinochetista de piñera que
representa sus antonio kast es un
peligro para el país y en particular
para la gente que más malo está pasando
finalmente en el minuto de oro ambos
candidatos y trataron de convencer a su
electorado
decirles como lo dije en el debate
anterior que vienen tiempos difíciles y
que se requiere un gobierno que dé
estabilidad a un gobierno que hable con
la verdad un gobierno que ejerza la
prudencia y la autoridad si por el
contrario quieren un cambio una
transformación en paz con orden
estabilidad pero la transformación
profunda para que tengamos mayor
justicia y dignidad los invito a hacerse
parte de este proyecto colectivo los
expertos califican estos comicios como
los más inciertos en 30 años
[Música]